it owns as a question
they are currently remaking this needs
the black hole the movie that you
claimed was the least accurate sci-fi
movie you ever saw what you excuse me
I've seen okay
there's nothing accurate about the Star
Wars series scientifically except the
double star system that sets a myth in
the desert so not even up for so it's
naughty so I don't judge movies by
whether they're inaccurate I'm just
saying the original Disney movie black
hole was awful it was awful and an actor
and inaccurate right words right they go
into a black and they go into the black
hole and it's like it's like this it's
this like written scene from from like a
beach party Arizona you know with with
vents spewing fire what are you doing I
couldn't I was in high school at the
time and I could have said look I could
have been your science advisor right on
a kick-butt movie on black holes I bet
you and ice will still knew a lot of
science yeah I taught a seminar on black
holes actually yeah well there you go
it's not the best example of someone
unknowledgeable about Legos you mean if
they make it I want to make sure they
have some advisors you know it don't
have to be me you want the black hole
would just be people turned into
spaghetti and then the movies done it's
about 35 seconds to identification no
but you can have the drama and the love
entering the event horizon after that
any more relationships and someone pull
gets pulled from them with the extended
outreach hands as they get spaghettified
that you want it to be a better story
that's what you really know my gosh oh
just yeah I hope and Disney's got a good
movie a good good money today and
there's science science matters now in
movies yeah James Jim camp is of your
tweets possibly but a Jim Cameron put
lot of science in Avatar
yes so that you can think about so he
clean plus horses really do plug into
the earth with USB ponytails yeah
exactly